[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about
sparsity compression compress sensing
and I want to take a step back and just
think about kind of sparsity and
parsimony in modeling in general okay so
sparsity as we've defined basically
means that you have some some data some
vector or array that is mostly
containing zeros but what it also means
in general is that out of many many
possible pieces of information there are
only a few pieces that actually matter
to you that's another way of thinking
about sparsity and so oftentimes you're
gonna hear me talk about parsimonious
models okay and parsimony is just a
fancy word for greedy but this isn't the
bad kind of greedy this is like greedy
in the sense that you want as little as
possible as few you want as few
descriptions as possible as few pieces
of information as you need to describe
some data or some phenomena but
absolutely no more so you want to be
greedy in how many numbers you need to
describe something or greedy in terms of
how many terms in a model you use to fit
some physical process so parsimony can
be a good thing and remember Gordon
Gekko from Wall Street greed is good
sometimes greed can be good in fact
that's one of my favorite papers is a
2004 paper by Joel trop titled greed is
good where he goes on to show kind of
the remarkable properties of sparse
optimization and greedy optimization for
robust robustly solving solving problems
in linear algebra
okay so sparsity is mathematically how
we often promote parsimony in our models
and our solutions and our signals and
our optimizations in general so if we're
optimizing for example of machine
learning you're trying to build models
to fit data now do you want a million
degrees of freedom that you can tweak
and use to fit your your data and your
model maybe but that's not a very
parsimonious solution maybe if there is
a model that is almost as good but it's
got three degrees of freedom three
parameters I'm gonna go with that one
every
okay every time I want the parsimonious
model and again parsimony for us often
means sparsely promoting sparsity in our
optimization and in our solution okay
this idea is absolutely not new so I'm
just gonna walk you through a couple of
examples of kind of how other people
have thought about parsimony and
sparsity in modeling the physical world
before us okay so I love this quote by
Einstein everything should be made as
simple as possible but not simpler this
is a great encapsulation of this
principle of parsimony he's talking
about physical laws and models so you
want to distill things down to the
absolute essentials the simplest
description you need to describe your
observations but no simpler because then
you can't describe your observations so
he may well have been talking about
Newton's second law F equals MA which is
kind of this it's the poster child for a
parsimonious model it's so simple yet it
describes so much or Einsteins own e
equals mc-squared
very very simple extremely descriptive
you can't go simpler and still describe
what we observe in the world okay so
that's that's a great encapsulation of
this principle of parsimony many of you
have heard of Occam's razor and with all
things being equal the simplest
explanation tends to be the right one
this this is actually called lex
parsimony in latin which means the law
of parsimony or kind of the stingy law
the greedy law the law that you know you
want the absolute simplest explanation
that's typically the right one okay so
Occam's razor is a great kind of
formalization of this concept it goes
farther back it goes back at believe
Aristotle had his own principle of
parsimony which might not surprise many
of you again you can observe this as
well if you're modeling the same natural
effects we must as far as possible
assign the same causes it would be too
complicated to say that different
physics governs different instances of
the same motion so for example Galileo
you know in his ball drop experiment
where he dropped different balls off of
the Tower of Giza
was was using this basic idea that you
can't have different physics governing
you know two different balls they're
probably governed by the same causes and
that's again formalized by Newton in his
in his laws of motion okay so he took
that observational data and he
formalized this into an extremely
parsimonious law good many of you have
heard of the Pareto rule the 80/20 rule
that roughly 80% of the effects come
from 20% of the causes this is another
take on that kind of parsimonious
principle and an Occam's razor okay you
can generally explain most things with a
relatively few or simple set of causes
okay so 80/20 is related if you go all
the way back actually I find this this
really interesting told me had the the
Ptolemaic system of how how planets move
in their orbits right so they this is
back in the Roman days he was describing
the motion of planets and stars and he
had this very simple description of
circles on circles on circles this
theory although it's not physically
correct right Newton and Kepler kind of
dethroned this this theory 1,500 years
later this idea stuck around for a
really long time 15 centuries because as
he explained it this was the simplest
hypothesis possible and it did a really
good job of describing the observational
data so the principle of parsimony to
some extent is what kept the Ptolemaic
system in place for 1500 years okay
until we had an even simpler explanation
for for the motion of the planets okay
so I kind of want to summarize a little
bit how we're gonna use this and why we
think this is important okay so in the
modern era we are building models from
data that is machine learning machine
learning is an optimization framework to
build models from data and parsimony is
just as important as it ever was maybe
more important when we're now training
our computers to model the world instead
of doing it ourselves so parsimonious or
sparse models are still important today
they have the property that by Road
ducing the amount of free variables or
parameters as much as possible to the
simplest possible explanation you tend
to prevent overfitting if I have a
million degrees of freedom that I get to
tweak a million parameters a very
complicated non parsimonious model if
I'm if I'm liberal with my parameters
then I might very well over fit and get
something that looks right on my data
but doesn't have the root cause kind of
encapsulated okay so parsimonious or
sparse models tend to over tend to
prevent overfitting I say sparse meaning
as few parameters or as few terms as
possible okay that's what we mean by
sparse these models generally are more
interpretable because again if I have
five parameters or five terms instead of
a million terms that's a lot less terms
to try to understand and to communicate
with other people to try to analyze okay
so sparse parsimonious models generally
are more interpretable they are the
models that require the fewest terms
needed to model the data that that's
what we mean by sparse or parsimonious
models and generally they're robust they
prevent overfitting they remain
interpretable this is what we want in
modeling okay so we're gonna talk about
sparsity and compression and the
mathematics of sparse vectors and sparse
arrays but I want you to remember why we
care so much about this aside from the
compression angle is that in machine
learning in the world of modeling with
data we again we still want parsimonious
models we still want to remember the
words of Einstein and Newton and Pareto
these are important we need to adhere to
Occam's razor when we model physical
systems okay so parsimonious or stingy
models are often the ones that I
personally personally want okay
thank you